all right she-hulk trailers out i'm
gonna talk about that trailer before i
finish talking about moon night i do
apologize for that i'm sure that's
really annoying for you the reason is
simple is because i missed a couple
episodes because i was either busy or
out of town and then i was like all
right well i guess i'll just binge the
rest of it when it came out and i
finally did do that long story short
moon night ended up being less
interesting than moon night started out
being even now i don't even know if i'm
inspired enough to talk about the rest
of moon knight but a she-hulk trailer
dropped i didn't even think i was going
to talk about this that's what my
channel's like right there i'm like
shadow from final fantasy 6. i hop in do
some stuff and then i'm out this trailer
did pleasantly surprise me probably
because i i didn't expect much from it
let's be clear let's address the cgi
elephant in the room right now the cgi
in this show is
it's like did marvel lose all their [ __ ]
you marvel money to wanda vision and
loki even moon knight cgi was like that
is not mcu cgi that we were promised so
yeah she hulk when she is she hulk
doesn't look as good cgi wise as we've
seen hulk look at first i was thinking
it was an uncanny valley thing like the
cgi was hidden [ __ ] hulk because hulk
looks like a monster who was a human but
because he looks more monstrous than
she-hulk it's easier to hide cgi on him
whereas she-hulk looks like a muscular
human who's green so it's easier for our
eyes to spot cgi on her then again the
age-tweaking cgi that marvel's done
looks better than she-hulk looks so i
guess that excuses out which funny
enough mark ruffalo's hulk is in this
show which raises a couple questions for
me because he seems to be professor hulk
like he was in avengers end game but i
thought he was done being professor hulk
i thought he was back to being bruce
banner because in xiang chi the post
credit scene in there he's back to being
bruce banner but now it looks like he's
back to being professor hulk sands the
armbrace which means one of two things
this either takes place before avengers
end game or i just have a lot of
questions maybe they're bringing on some
of that fox x-men continuity after they
bought fox but also professor hulk being
with she-hulk you have two very smart
self-aware hulks essentially the
contrast between she-hulk and hulk and
what i found interesting about she-hulk
is essentially gone she's less unique
now because she-hulk isn't just some
enormous green rage monster super id
smashing through everything she-hulk
when she is she-hulk maintains her
ego super-ego sense of self i always
found that really cool that she gets
that but bruce banner doesn't but now
bruce banner does have that so it's like
okay well she hooks less unique now good
job mcu in your quest to domesticate the
hulk you made she-hulk less interesting
by contrast now as i keep saying we're
in the deep cuts of mcu characters and
well rather marvel comic book characters
she-hulk's one i actually do have a
little bit of experience in
that much the 90s animation and marvel
heroes
still making those references baby but i
bring this up because of the comedic
tone of this trailer and apparently the
show like the mcu has become
action sci-fi comedies they're very much
comedies these days she hulk seems to
feed into that comedic persona that the
mcu has been going for for the past few
years but unlike some other marvel
characters she-hulk does fit that
she-hulk from what i know of the
character has always been funny sassy
and quippy so the tone of the trailer
does work one of the things i liked you
just get a peek of tim roth is in the
show abomination we remember him back
when the hulk was edward norton back
when bruce banner was edward norton also
in that phase of the mcu going we really
we're not even in mcu yet we really need
to prove ourselves to become an mcu
right now we're just a couple movies
with hope but tim roth is super
underrated also very underutilized in
this universe we saw the abomination in
spider-man no way home but it was still
abomination i like the fact that it's
tim roth sitting there who then turns
into abomination but still i will give
props to this trailer for the truest
statement that was ever spoken there's
truth there's justice and then there is
this this is everything when people are
like hey can i swear in a bible they do
it so they can just implied they would
be half as truthful as this statement
right here your ass looks crazy right
now yeah you said it lady look in the
end she-hulk when i heard about it i was
like i will say but the trailer
surprised me thus i talked about it here
as much as i'd love to say well the cgi
they have time to refine it they won't
i've been in that boat before this is
probably when the largest movie studio
on earth is like okay we have enough to
show the trailer
i feel like that the cgi is about as
done as it's gonna be for me and all the
mcu shows there's always diminishing
returns as the show goes on
i have that perpetual feeling of this
probably could have been a shorter show
or a movie if you do the math it's like
you're talking about a movie at that
point we'll see how it goes i'm not
expecting anything different from this
show so if it surprises me all i can do
is be surprised regardless tatiana
mislani i think she's a great casting i
think she's gonna do a great job in the
show if for nothing else we have a new
show in which i'll do a video in the
first couple episodes then just
bounce shadow from final fantasy 6 folks
that's what i'm saying all right so the
trailer to she-hulk have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
fine
[Music]
if hulk won't smash anymore i guess i
will at least for one video that's we're
good right we're good for the next year
of no no punches
cool